Let's take a look at the line
of succession to the British throne.
Of course, Prince Charles - the Queen's firstborn - becomes King.
In a surprise move, the Queen announced in February of this year that Camilla
Duchess of Cornwall, will be known
as Queen Consort,
not Princess Consort as previously arranged.
After Prince Charles
King Charles, his eldest son Prince William is next in line to the throne.
His wife Kate Middleton will become Queen Consort,
married to a King rather than a ruling Queen in the traditional sense.
Their firstborn
Prince George comes next after his father.
If he doesn't want the crown
his sister Princess Charlotte would take his place and become the reigning Queen
like her great-grandmother.
Younger sibling Prince Louis is fifth in line.
And if by small chance none of them work out
here's Harry.
That’s right
he's still 6th in line,
the Duke of Sussex
with a slim chance of becoming the King of Britain.